[Musique]
sortir de chez vous pour vous faire
recenser venez vous faire compter pour
le recensement de 2010
les touches je viens
tout amer vient
on ne parlait pas de notre corps
[Musique]
nous a donné deux jours pour pardonner
aux agresseurs avant leur retour
on savait à peine lire et écrire mais ce
jour-là on a appris à voter
ne rien faire restez se battre partir
ces hommes nous renonçons à notre place
au ciel
il doit bien y avoir quelque chose qui
vaut la peine d'être vécu dans cette vie
et pas que dans la suivante
on sait aujourd'hui qu'on n'a pas
imaginé ces agressions on sait qu'on est
meurtri et affecté et mis enceinte que
plus d'une on est morte
on ne peut pas pardonner parce qu'on y
est forcé
de quel droit
[Musique]
toutes les
semaines comme si j'avais le choix
[Musique]
on sait qu'on doit tout pré protéger nos
enfants
fait devenir une meurtrière si je reste
on n'est pas toutes des meurtrières pas
encore
et ils ont enseigné la leçon de la
domination et les petits garçons se sont
avérés d'excellents élèves mais ce sont
aussi des enfants que l'on peut éduquer
à vous nous priver une décision
notre choix
déterminera ton avenir